[Music]
hi everyone
welcome to our
diversity and leadership panel with
diversity equity and inclusion
practitioners at stanford university
and beyond my name is jessica chung i'm
an admissions officer
at the stanford graduate school of
business mba admissions office
very excited to welcome you here today
had the privilege of observing our
students and faculty this week discuss
diversity
not as a status to be achieved but as
continual and intentional work
and we're excited to talk today with
some incredible folks
doing the work of diversity equity and
inclusion
as you know we have several panelists
joining us i do want to
mention that one of our panelists eric
abrams who is the chief inclusion
officer at the graduate school of
education will be joining us a bit later
in the session
he's currently moderating an event with
um
ibram ex kendy at the graduate school of
education
so he might be able to share some wisdom
when he's able to join us later in the
session
but i'm excited to get started with our
amazing panelists who are on the line
with us already
i'll let them introduce themselves so
for our panelists if you could introduce
yourself with your
name your role or your title um how long
you've been a part of the
stanford community and maybe your
favorite
lunch spot in the area
zaba do you what would you like to stop
thank you so much for the introduction
jessica hi everyone we're so excited to
have you all here
my name is saba khan and i head up
the outreach team in mba admissions
which means all of our global recruiting
including all of our diversity equity
and inclusion
strategy and work um i have been at the
gsp for
about 10 years which is always a
surprise to me some days i wake up and
i'm like i
must really like my job because i'm
still here um
it's just been an amazing journey and
um that's been really you know obviously
these times are so crazy thinking about
a food spot on campus is very nostalgic
for
me right now so i'm gonna go with the
most nostalgic which would
just be the arbuckle cafeteria like the
opportunity to leave your desk at lunch
and it's actually if you look at
jessica's
screen background it's that round
building right behind her and it just
has these amazing like
indoor outdoor um you know obviously in
california it's great weather so
students just pour
out of the cafeteria there actually are
really good farm to table options i know
that sounds very california but it is
um so i would just say i kind of missed
that
that spot for those reasons
awesome thank you saba simone would you
like to introduce yourself
or good morning afternoon evening
depending on where you are
there may be some people that are
already in tomorrow so hello from the
past
hope the future is even brighter i'm
super excited to be
here with all of you today my name is
simone hill
i currently work at omidyar network
leading up our equity and belonging work
and also managing our grants portfolio
around racial justice
i've been with the organization for
about two years
i've been affiliated with stanford since
2012 technically i am a
gsb alum from the class of 2014
and while i was there i did the joint
degree with the school of education
as well um and then i worked in the mba
admissions team
i've been an alumni interviewer for the
past few years um
tons of different touch points clearly i
can't get enough um
of this school um my favorite spot
um it took me a while to think about it
but when i finally thought about koopa
all of the things that i buy there came
flooding back so um koopa cafe there's a
number of different
um uh locations on campus um including
one right on the gsb's campus but
i think my favorite was the one near um
kind of the larger library actually near
the school of education
um they have an incredible black forest
ham and swiss sandwich
and my favorite thing to get from there
was a tiger spice
chai tea um so now my i'm
salivating a little bit just thinking
about
about that but yeah that's me
dr thomas would you like to introduce
yourself
sure i'm idly thomas i'm the associate
dean for graduate and career education
in the school of medicine
focusing on the biosciences masters and
phd programs
we i oversee academic student services
for
students in the school of medicine i've
been at stanford
continuously since 1997.
i got my phd here in electrical
engineering
uh then worked for the school of
humanities and sciences for 12 years
before coming over to the school of
medicine
so know quite a bit about lots of
different random parts of campus
for my favorite food like simone
koopa cafe i had a chance to come on
campus last week to pick up a new
computer
and the one thing that i wanted to get
that i actually did get
was the maya spicy hot cocoa from koopa
that and their buttermilk pancakes all
day long
so sometimes my lunch is hot cocoa and
pancakes just because i can't
thank you all so much for those
wonderful introductions
um hopefully one day we will all be back
on campus and able to enjoy hot
chocolate and pancakes that sounds
wonderful
before we dive in i do want to
acknowledge that this
month november is native american
heritage month
and i want to recognize that stanford
university sits on the homelands
of the ohlone tribe and i think
this work of diversity equity and
inclusion
as provost drell stated in her her
statement on diversity inclusion
it is in part to fulfill the mission of
higher education it is also
in part to grapple with the history of
marginalization in which
universities have been
i think that is therefore important to
acknowledge the
land on which stanford university sits
and the
historical context of this work
that it is not merely as i said earlier
a status to be achieved but
work that is critical continual and
intentional
so thank you all so much for being here
today
and thank you to our panelists for those
incredible introductions
sort of related to getting to know you
all and getting to
getting to learn about your journeys to
this work i was wondering if you could
share a little bit about what brought
you
to diversity equity and inclusion work
and
kick us off there whoever wants to start
i guess i could start so for me it's
i would say it's a generations long
passion my family's been involved in
social rights and racial justice uh
for at least 200 years back to the times
when my ancestors were enslaved i'm in
kentucky
i'm here in this country and that work
has really just been continuous
i think for me when i got into high
school and college i really got
involved in a lot of mentoring and
advocating with administrations and
things like that
about changing particularly kind of
process and policy
uh recognizing that that was one of the
real kind of barriers
to people being able to excel and to
achieve their full potential i did not
intend to go into this work
i actually intended to be an engineering
faculty member
studying parallel computer architectures
but decided against going into faculty
work
around the third or fourth year of my
graduate education
and really stumbled into my first dei
job when i was
pregnant had just defended and my
husband was in seminary and so i needed
some i need we needed some health
insurance like real health insurance
and was kind of pondering um stanford's
help ads and saw this job description
for a multicultural student affairs
officer
in the school of humanities and sciences
and when i read the description
it was everything that i was doing in my
free time
so all the advocating the working with
undergrads encouraging them to go to
grad school
putting on programs you know meeting
with administration
managing budgets that was all the things
i was doing anyways
and i realized that that was actually
where my passion was
i enjoyed studying engineering but what
the work that i wanted to do was
actually more as an educator and so
went into work first is kind of a
strictly a diversity
equity and inclusion officer and then
over the years because of my engineering
background partly
my portfolio will expand a lot to
include things like student data
student data fellowship coordination and
lots of other things as well
but even as kind of an administrator who
oversees an entire
division office in the school of
medicine the heart of what we do
continues to be really based in ideas
around diversity equity and inclusion
and how we can ensure that for every
student who's in our programs
awesome thank you so much and yeah i
think it's
i think a lot of people will relate to
the part of your story
in which they're doing this work
uncompensated so
yes absolutely get that paper we love it
um who would like to share their journey
to this work next
i can al go ahead sure
um so i think like many admissions
officers
you don't necessarily grow up as a kid
being like i want to be an admissions
officer one day whereas like my sister
who's a physician
like knew from a young age she wanted to
be a doctor like it's a job that
is very accessible to one's imagination
um
this job i actually um was never
intentional about pursuing a higher
education career in particular i
previously was
a humanitarian so i actually worked in
refugee camps
across southern africa and
then pursued graduate study around
international development
and humanitarian affairs and purely
coincidentally
during my grad school experience as part
of my scholarship financial aid had a
work-study job
and randomly was placed in the
admissions office
for my work-study job in graduate school
and um it just really got me thinking
about global economic access and
educational access
from a totally different vantage point
of not only what happens in the field
when you work internationally
in in those communities but also the
ways in which
talent is just left out of so many
pipelines
from a global perspective and um
you know even when you look at the cost
of the stanford mba program
what a huge inhibitor or pro prohibitor
that is
and for our access to talent and for
who's represented in our program so when
i started at the gsb was really thinking
about
we have some major gaps in terms of
geography
and a lot of that is driven by a by
financial hardship
and so um started launching programs
focused on
africa and then later more broadly
emerging markets and now i
oversee global recruiting so i really
came at it from a financial and
educational access perspective but over
the years
have had the wonderful privilege to
learn from so many of my colleagues
about um integrating that into an even
bigger picture around
equity issues broadly including all of
the historical
context around educational access within
the us
and and so that's just been an
incredible
marriage in expansion of my mindset
around dei and kind of starting from an
international perspective and now
really um just being so excited about
the opportunity and potential in the
future from from this broader umbrella
and really seeing admissions as a very
unique access point
um just when we talk about structural
racism or systemic oppression
higher education is one of those
structures it is one of those systems
and so admissions
plays a very just critical
gatekeeping role and so thinking about
what happens when you try to dismantle
that system from within
is a role that i feel really
privileged to help play a part in
um so for me i uh similar to
io and saba definitely um did not
kind of grow up feeling like i'm gonna
you know work in in diversity equity and
inclusion
um but from a very young age i had this
question in the back of my mind of like
why me and typically it was a why only
me
um so i ended up being the first in my
family um to go um to college
therefore the first to go to grad school
so on and so forth
um i came from a low-income background
um
and but i came from a very large family
i'm one of five my mom's one of eleven
my dad was one of five
very large and yet i was you know the
only and so
for quite some time i had a question in
the back of my head of like well why
um if we grew up very similarly you know
had
similar um school systems and access to
staples point
why right and so my um
journey towards kind of a career in
diversity equity and inclusion
really started um when i got to the gsb
as a student
um really coming to the gsb with that
same question of like
it's and it's not just me that has the
why me question like there's a lot of
people that come from marginalized
backgrounds that have a similar story
um and why is it that um there are
you know fewer black and brown people
that are are actually making it
into and through college right and so my
similar to saba
journey started with this coming from
the space of access
and then really expanded to the space of
what success looks like
um in college and so as a student
um at the gsb um my uh dead school on
part of my degree was really focused on
higher education and specifically kind
of that gap between
k-12 and higher education which is a
huge gap for
a lot of different groups um and then
really focused on what are some of the
different
elements of um the the college
experience that
lead to dropout stop-outs um people just
not making it through to graduation and
that kind of got me into my work um
working at the gsb
and mba admissions um where i managed
our strategy for
what diversity looks like at the gsb how
do we
attract more diverse talent um how do we
think about doing that in an equitable
way
um how do we help people i always saba
knows this
um say like see themselves here right
how do
we help people understand that they
actually belong here right
um and that experience was kind of my
first official role
um working in diversity equity and
inclusion i had previous roles in which
i worked with diverse communities but
that was my first kind of
diversity strategy role and it taught me
a ton um
about again barriers um and and um
barriers to access and then i decided
that i really wanted to
focus a little bit more on kind of a
more holistic experience
and and wanting to do that in the in the
workplace um
and for me understanding that the
workplace is where for the most of
most of us we will spend the majority of
our lives love it and hate it
and um if that's the case since that is
actually the case um how i've been
really driven towards um thinking
through how do we
um then make that space um as
uh diverse as equitable and inclusive as
possible
um how do we make people feel like they
belong from the very first time they see
our job description or
very first time they see anything um
related to what we do as an organization
um and just wanting to give people that
sense of
you do belong here right um yes you may
um
you know to quote our um future vice
president um
you may be the first one right but
hopefully you will not be the only one
right and so really creating
that that space for people um this was
driven me to where i am today
awesome thank you all so much for
sharing your personal stories and i
think
through your personal stories
i think really demonstrating how
long-standing so many of these barriers
to
access to opportunity to resources
there are in our society
and i think we of course are in a very
a very the word unprecedented gets
thrown around a lot we're in a very
unprecedented current moment
in which we're grappling with a global
pandemic
we're seeing i think long-standing
uprisings around social justice
and racial quality i think finally
getting the visibility that they have
always deserved
um and so i'm wondering from your
perspectives what opportunities does
this current moment offer us and what
challenges does it also present
i think the biggest opportunity i see is
that people are talking about it
that in corners of the of the university
of corporations of communities
people are actively and openly talking
about
issues particularly as it regards to
race
that we have been avoiding having
conversations about in spite of the fact
that it's been the reality for
hundreds of years in this country and
around the world as well
so i think that that opportunity is
people are willing to have the
conversation
people are seeing things that have been
happening for
once again generations in a different
light and kind of finally sinking in
what this means
and they're willing to actually try to
make change
i think the challenge comes in because
making changes
hard and especially when people have not
been having these conversations or
having that for the first time
it can be very difficult and challenging
and then you throw
covet on top of that as well at the same
moment and sometimes
for my staff what this means is we would
have already been working overtime
just dealing with covid just because
nature of our work
now you add this heightened emphasis on
dei
and so everyone who is doing this work
is being pulled in five million
directions
and the the charge to manage
our self-care while we're kind of
pushing through this open door
to try and push real systemic change is
another real
challenge because if we burn ourselves
out then we're not here to continue that
work in the next years to come
when a lot of these things will actually
be put in place
yeah i would just add um you know people
have been calling this moment and
awakening some people have seen it been
saying it's a reckoning
um i definitely echo the fact that um
i'm just excited that people are are
starting to to
understand um and become more aware
right because
in my opinion the problems are not new
the the technology and access and
vision of the problems is the new part
right um like we've
if we think about the murder of george
floyd um
that um is not new um you can think even
in our own lifetime um
we've seen um different um episodes
of of excessive force um by by the
police and so
none of these things to me at least are
new um but what is new for sure is this
new sense of awareness
um and this new sense of interest i
think the challenge right now
um um or i should say one more
opportunity is that
i think whether it's in the workplace um
or even in friend groups and even in
family groups
um people are requiring a lot more than
um previously
um that the places that they work for
actually care about
this which is which is great that that
adds pressure that makes
change the challenge with that um
is that there are some companies that
absolutely want to
and decide to focus on this because they
do care and some of it
honestly is performative if i'm being
quite honest right
and performative kind of activism or
focus on dei
is i can be extremely detrimental to a
long-term journey
um and so for me when i think about and
and what i look for
um in terms of like seeing if a company
or an organization is really serious
about what they say about
diversity equity and inclusion or or
more specifically racial justice
um is the actual actions right um are
they
putting resources towards this both head
count and budget
um are do they have um a specific person
or people that are responsible like
actual um accountability mechanisms
being set up for this
um have they actually stated this not
just stated this but
embedded it into the organization's
goals and objectives right
um all of those things to me are much
more of an indicator than just
a public statement um or even just like
a massive training that they make
everyone do
right um so so so i think there's a lot
of room
um for opportunity for to see real
change and
my hope is that for sure that this is
actually a movement um
versus just a moment that will pass by
i completely echo and agree with
everything that's been said and i really
do
share that sentiment that i think the
biggest opportunity right now is the
opportunity to harness the energy
that that exists and i think attention
management
is something that we probably haven't
put as much thought
into but now in the era of you know
i feel like in some ways it took a
global pandemic of everyone
being at home and having their attention
i think more focused in one way
is part of what i think sparked a lot of
the um
movements that we've seen in the in the
movement for
black lives and and i feel like that's
something that we need to
harness and it's a resource that's
available to us that wasn't necessarily
before and i think the challenges
are really similar to what's been shared
too a related subject to the idea of
performative um dei
is the concept of moral licensing and i
think
that's something that i just worry about
i think
as a potential challenge but also i
would kind of frame it as like a pitfall
that i just hope we're able to avoid so
um if you want to read more about moral
licensing i would
recommend actually reading the work of
professor maggie neil who's a gsb
professor here um
and the concept is basically by
saying that we have work
around dei whether it's a council or a
task force or we have a racial equity
plan
that that then gives us the moral
license
to say that we are an equitable
organization or we've created a space of
belonging or that diversity
has been addressed and tackled and so
it's a way to pat ourselves on the back
for having done something and yet
it may not actually be leading to the
results that prove
that we've created impact and so that's
just
a pitfall that i'm trying to make sure
we work around um given the sense of
urgency and focus
on this issue but also you know when i
think back to some of the most
successful work that we've done around
access
it has taken i would say
you know for the decade that i've been
here that's how long the work has taken
to get us to where we are and i'm sure
that will continue to be true
for the rest of my career so i think
just having that longitudinal
perspective is another thing that i
think is an opportunity and a challenge
at the same time
awesome thank you all so much for your
really thoughtful responses it makes me
think about
um i think another framework i've heard
is differentiating between
reformist reforms and non-reformist
reforms
which i know they're both sort of a
mouthful but
um i think when you think about
what is performative those are the sorts
of reforms that
just maintain sort of the traditional
structures that allow them to um
progress enough to avoid critical
scrutiny but overall sort of maintain
the status quo and those are reformist
reforms
but non-reformist reforms are really
attempts to transform
the structures that we're in to make
them meaningfully
more equitable
and to really to shatter the status quo
but i think as saba mentioned earlier
it's it's complicated work when you're
working from the inside
um i love what simone said too about
accountability especially as we're
talking about how do you
differentiate performative allyship from
really meaningful change and i was
wondering
about your perspectives for our
panelists your perspectives on
how do we hold
institutions and decision makers
accountable
for making changes that will promote
equity diversity and inclusion
one of the conversations i know we've
had a lot on our team
is around the power of transparency
i feel like it's a theme
that i'm really encouraged to actually
see
a lot of this happening and it's only
the first step
like transparency does not mean that
we've solved the problem but it means
that we've named the problem and i think
there's a james baldwin quote and i
don't want to
deign to butcher it but it's like you
know something cannot be
fixed if it cannot be seen or named and
i think the power of transparency
is a really tactical tangible thing that
people
understand the power of so one of the
things we did this year for example was
to
publish a full ethnicity breakdown of
our mba class which we hadn't done
before
like by ethnicity including
intersectionality including
multiracial identities um including
at the percentage of the class that was
the first in their families to go to
college like
thinking how do we actually be
more visible so that we can at least
hold ourselves accountable to
demonstrate progress
to demonstrate success um
i just i feel like that it's a tool so
it's not necessarily it's there are
absolutely no silver bullets i think for
as many problems there are as many ways
to hold ourselves accountable and
and there's ways we can do it in
personal individual behaviors and
actions but i would say
one of the helpful tactical near-term
things that i feel like we've been able
to leverage has been
transparency as a way to just like open
the door a little bit
yeah and i would i would just add to
that i think that's that's that's
totally right
i mean you can't um change the things
that you don't see
right so if you are continuing to kind
of um
uh kind of layer different different
elements um onto the problem it just
makes it really difficult
to like understand what's at the root um
and i think for us uh where i'm working
um
a lot of what we're doing is is that on
the kind of policy and practices fronts
um so things around
um how we do performance ratings how we
do
um uh how we make decisions for
compensation um
as you were hired um a lot of different
um
processes that we started to to set up
are quite
focused um on making sure that first
there's equity but we are
um being transparent as we possibly can
without you know um
giving away someone's personal
information um to help people understand
what's going into the decisions that are
being made
um because i think there are a number of
organizations that are being
becoming more transparent about the
decision um but not the process that
it took to get there so that's a really
important
um piece as well and then for us like
there's a ton of
um data for example that which we just
don't have that we're trying to collect
so that we can get more transparent
about what
what what the problems are so i saw in
the in the q a there's been like
questions about like desegregation
for different racial groups um um i
think a lot of conversations have been
had
about uh that for the aapi community um
the asian american pacific islander um
more specifically um we're starting to
and
internally for us have those
conversations about um the latinx
community as well that's also a very
large group of folks right um that that
don't have the
necessarily the same cultures the same
access the same um
kind of uh kind of public perception
um you know um especially when it comes
to kind of job roles
um so we are also trying to um get
a little bit clearer for our own our own
selves about what that looks like
um so that we can then set clearer
targets we can
um have much clearer a clearer
understanding of where our gaps are and
what we need to do
yeah i think i would agree with
everything that is said and what adds to
that as well that when you think about
kind of idea
of performative versus things that
actually are deep substantial changes
is that one of the tensions that's in
place i think particularly the
university environment
is you often have students demanding
immediate change
but the reality is that systemic change
is not fast
because cultural change in organizations
is not fast
and so anything that can be done within
six months
will not last six years and so part of
it really is being willing to say
that this process is going to take time
if we're going to
actually unpack policies and
and procedures and things that may be
kind of holding
systemic racism in place that doesn't
happen
overnight changing people's minds
doesn't happen overnight
changing the admissions process does not
happen overnight
and so you have to be willing to have
that patience to kind of
work through the process because the one
thing
that um i've learned kind of in
leadership training over the years is
the
idea that you know a culture eats
strategy for lunch
which means that when you're trying to
change cultures
you have to bring people along with you
and not just
kind of force them to do something
because that usually means that they're
not really having that meaningful change
in the local processes and things that
need to take place
so really that the other kind of danger
piece of performative as well
comes into a too much focus on
collecting information
um i've seen some beautiful reports
written that took two
years to create that then no one did
anything with
and so it's so important to balance
to ask what you really don't know
because a lot of times we're surveying
things that we already know the answer
to
you know you should survey the pieces
you don't know the answer to
not the components that you heard 50
reports on and that you're very clear
this is a problem
and so you could start working on those
things for which you already have
clear information on while you're doing
that data collection and things for the
components for which you don't
versus waiting for one big huge
beautiful report
to then take any action and so i think
that's one of the ways where people kind
of
do all this work and then they're worn
out at the end and nothing has changed
and it's because all the effort was put
on kind of the pre-document
and not on actually starting to do that
real kind of introspective work
that needs to happen in organizations to
really push change for the long term
can i just add one one thing that i
think that's total i i totally agree
with you on that i o and i think
uh for individuals that may be on the
call that either work in diversity
equity and inclusion or interested in
doing so
um in some way shape or form um one of
the big things i
always tell people is to understand that
this is a marathon not a sprint
um and it's a very difficult um balance
that you you'll need to have of like
having
patience but also balancing that with
this sense of urgency that you may feel
and
you may be getting pressure from other
people in your organization um to do as
well and so
i try to focus on like having a
focus on progress um with a healthy dose
of patients right
as long as i feel like there is actual
progress being
made um in a clear way in a way in which
again we are holding the right people
accountable
um we are actually measuring the right
metrics to io's point about asking the
right questions um
that is super important to me um and
being very very clear and understanding
that if you get into this work
it it will be some of the most um
frustrating thing that you think that
you do um but also
some of the most like invigorating and
um
exceptional things that you'll do with
your life
awesome thank you all so much for those
responses and
um i'd like to encourage our attendees
so if you have any questions
please feel free to throw them in the q
a i feel like we could talk about these
topics
all day we have about we have a little
over 20 minutes left in our session
which i hope will be one of many
conversations we continue
to have about how to do this work um
because
as our panelists have said it's it's
truly a marathon not a sprint
um and i i completely appreciate that
for let's see
for folks on the line i think they might
be wondering
what small steps or concrete action
items you could remem
recommend for advancing dei
in their spaces um and
maybe small is not quite the right word
um but perhaps you know concrete
evidence
or sustained actions that people might
be able to take to really meaningfully
change their environments if you all
have any recommendations
i think one of the first things
particularly for organizations is that
we all know
that it is our structures that drives
action
the fact that we have a finance team is
why finances
always have a focus the fact that we
have you know other types of teams
is the reason why they have that focus
so you've really got to establish
a some kind of a team of people not just
dei
professionals but people who really span
your stakeholders and populations
who are going to be committed to coming
together not just for a short period of
time
but kind of as a standing committee
group of your organization
not the same people for the entire time
but this idea once again of creating
an official infrastructure that has
support from your institution
that can once again carry on this
marathon of work
what you don't want is for it to be
built on a few people and personalities
because people leave and if it's built
on them when they leave all the work is
gone
but if you build an actual
infrastructure to support this sustained
work
then you're much more likely to have
progress that's long lasting because
once again
this is not a task force that is set to
expire in 12 months
this is a permanent a permanent group
that will have members replaced over
time
as people leave to ensure that there is
continuity
in pressure and change
thank you so much did you want to go
sava
like what i have said
i agree with that i think there is
something
on a personal accountability level that
i would also encourage
people to take seriously because
i do feel like there is an
opportunity for dialogue
in a way that a vocabulary or a lexicon
maybe hasn't been as accessible to
everyone who's joining this conversation
now
and so i appreciate
all of the um
i feel like there's been really valid
criticisms
around how far um individual dialogue
can go
but at the same time i would say like
don't
lean out of that if it's available to
you and take the personal responsibility
to engage in that dialogue
even if it is difficult even if it is
draining even if you feel like you're
not well equipped even if you're scared
of saying the wrong thing like those are
all feelings that i've had
personally um and
i feel like having courage like just on
a personal individual like
learning to flex that muscle is
something i would encourage
people to consider doing i know that's
way easier said than done
um but you know we have tools at the gsb
i think
you know going back to that question of
like some of the opportunities that have
been created like i feel like the amount
of
tools and resources that are available
the onus is on us to actually leverage
and internalize what's
available now and so i would encourage
people just as like
a first step on a personal
accountability level if it's
not familiar to you to or even if it is
we're all learning
and we're all still going to continue to
learn and so i
i feel like some of the things that even
just what the gsb has created
um you know we have a seven-day
anti-racism and allyship journey it's
a set of materials and content created
by gsb faculty members who have
focused on social movements and racial
justice
and it's free it's self-paced you can
take it for 45 minutes a day for seven
days
um or even something really simple and
tactical
like put one hour on your calendar two
weeks from now
and just put it on there like create
space
for myself like that's something we've
been asked to do by the gsb
and it's just that is not going to solve
the long-term structure and systems that
i
was talking about and i 100 support that
i feel like for anyone that's looking
for like
what's one thing i could do today like
this is just
a very first step that i would
i would say i would i would totally echo
that
and just underscore the importance of
learning starting with yourself and
learning on your own first um
there's been a lot of talk especially um
post uh
george floyd and kind of this um
reemergence of the the black lives
matter movement
um there's been a lot of talking
especially in the black community about
the emotional burden of
having to answer questions uh about like
the black
experience um and while i i do
encourage you for sure to understand it
um
and and ask questions and things of that
nature just be very very mindful
of the fact that it's it's exhausting
right um and so
google can be your best friend uh masava
also gave you
some great um some great uh um
options as well as well for this um i
think that
um the other thing especially if you're
if you're looking to do
um kind of work within your organization
um like
even a small starting things and my
assumption is that the majority of you
are not holding an actual
dei role at your organization um there
are just
smaller things that you can do right um
you can um host a meeting
um and kind of send an article out to
everyone just to say like hey i want to
get
get a conversation started about this
like i know i might i might not be an
expert in this
i may not even be an expert facilitator
right but i would love to just
open the door and create a space in
which we can start having a culture in
which we can discuss these things
together as an organization
so something as small as that um can
really
get the ball moving um in your
organization to have um
much more difficult and complex
conversations about dei
hi eric hello
um sorry everyone that i'm late
we're so glad you're able to join do you
want to introduce yourself
your name your role and um how long
you've been at stanford
how long i've been at stanford is a
complicated question depending on how
you ask i was a
stanford undergrad worked in undergrad
admissions worked for athletics
did a couple of stints in the mba
admissions office currently i
am the chief inclusion officer at the
graduate school of education a post i've
held for three and a half years
thank you so much for being here we're
really excited to chat with you
and perhaps you'll have some insights
from your previous event to share with
us i know you were just
speaking with um ibrahim kennedy is that
right yeah
yeah our uh our our external relations
team
um had a had a zoom talking about his
how to be an anti-racist and how can an
institution at a place like stanford
um become more anti-racist and it was it
was a fascinating discussion
yeah absolutely um that's actually a
great segue into
one of the questions from our attendees
who asks
how how can we implement dei work in
organizations
especially those that are wedded to
tradition
[Music]
or conservative that are perhaps
inherently patriarchal and um
prestigious um yeah any suggestions for
how we can do this work in
institutions that perhaps are resistant
to the kind of change that we want to
see
the first thought that comes that comes
to mind is is
i think it's important for us to do a
really good job of showing how this is
in the institution's interest
um you know a an institution that
doesn't take
any institution that doesn't take
advantage of the full talents of the
and range of people that are out there
is going to be left behind by
institutions who do
right uh i i imagine that if the
university
still had an entirely male faculty and
staff
it would be left in the dust by a place
that had a more
inclusive faculty and staff i think the
same thing true
is true for issues of race um the
challenge is how do we find the data and
really demonstrate
that that creating institutions that are
better for
all are actually better for all
yeah absolutely i think um derek bell
who is a sort of a pioneering scholar in
critical race theory talks about
interest convergence being
one of the best tools for pushing
pushing this work forward
any other insights from our panelists
yeah i think one other thing that's
important to recognize is that because
of the nature of these institutions
you cannot expect people to have
even what you can assume is the base
level of knowledge
about our nation's history about issues
of systemic racism or sexism or any of
the other isms as well
that you really have to assume that
you're going to need
to bring people along from where they
are
so if you walk into a room in a meeting
and you scoff at anyone who doesn't
understand what happened during slavery
slavery
well that may be because they're an
immigrant and they never had u.s history
so therefore they really don't
understand what happened
and the implications for today so really
i think kind of being open to
and to acknowledge the fact that people
come with many different
levels of knowledge and being able to
kind of take those who are already there
and start moving with them immediately
but then also providing
information and support for those who
are of good will but are just ignorant
to help them get to the point where they
can be more actively engaged too
i think one thing i would add too is
just the power and potential in
coalition building
i think there are often groups who do
have buy-in or who do have power or have
gained traction in some way in these
issues
or they might be your customers or they
might be your
clients or they might be other people to
whom
any given organization could be held
accountable so
i would just say like also don't go it
alone
like try to find a way to create
an opportunity where it's a win-win like
it doesn't have to be antagonistic
even if they're if even if it feels like
there's resistance
there's got i feel like finding those
opportunities just building on the point
eric made before
it can it can be helpful to find who
your allies are in the broadest sense
whether it's other stakeholders who
might have more influence or authority
than you
or even just creating power in numbers
by having
you know employees come together or
um you know just aligning around broader
mission and goals can be
another tool to think about yeah i just
echo what saba said um
i think especially up until recently and
even still to some extent um
uh recently the majority of
organizations
um ha don't right have a chief dei
officer or don't have a committee or a
task force
um until there is somewhat of a like
groundswell grassroots movement
um and coalition building like weather
and and sometimes it is
like started and and really lifted up by
um underrepresented groups in the
organization sometimes it's it's a it's
a
coalition across backgrounds um and i
love what eric said about um helping the
organization
understand the the impact um and
sometimes it is just a conversation
about
bottom line right this is how your
bottom line will be impacted if you if
we aren't thinking about this
the one last thing i'll say is um and
just to kind of like be
realistic about this is um from my
experience
if you don't or cannot um see a path to
getting buy-in from the most senior
leadership
honestly it's it's going to be like
pushing a huge boulder up against
a like completely vertical hill
um you can get some things done um
uh and around around your organization
um without it
um but for it to um have really long
lasting change like io said
um it's going to have to have buy-in and
ideally active sponsorship from at least
a couple of the senior leaders in your
organization and so
what eric said about kind of making the
case uh for
what this means for the organization and
the the success
of the organization may be a good way to
get to start getting that buy-in
i would throw one other piece in there
as well because i also don't want people
to kind of go away thinking well
if my leadership is not you know down
for it then that means we can't do
anything
a lot of times people don't see
their own power to impact process
and policy if you are running or
managing a fellowship program
or you are running some kind of a
program you can look at your own
processes for how you are engaging are
you considering people from different
ability levels and being able to
access your information are you
considering your application process
are you assist considering your timing
there's lots of things you can do
locally to consider
how issues around inclusion and
belonging
impact can be impacted by the work you
are doing personally
and so once again not overlooking those
things that you directly touch
and can actually push and slipped a
little bit to make things
more equitable to create a greater sense
of belonging for people in your
community
yeah thank you so much for that i think
that that touches on another question
that a lot of our attendees are asking
about
sort of pipeline issues how to
um since we're all working sort of at
the graduate level
how do we think about that funnel that
brings people into
the graduate experience or in simone's
case into the
um into professional spaces how do we
think about widening that
making sure that it's inclusive and
diverse um
and i think another question that is
coming up a lot in
di work whether it is widening that
funnel or other sorts of di initiatives
how are we measuring progress
i know we don't have a ton of time left
so you can pick which part of that
that really big question you want to
tackle but i'd be interested to hear how
people are thinking about
widening the funnel and how do we
measure progress in this kind of work
so i don't know how happy you'll be with
my answer
but i would just consider another
framing when you think about the
pipeline on the top of the funnel
um and i guess this might be just really
specific to a school that's as highly
selective as stanford is
but i would say when i look at the
priority of challenges that we face
around having inclusive talent um
i would actually say it really is later
stages of the funnel that i have more
concern about
than how wide the funnel is at the top
and i think we are really and this could
be a very privileged and fortunate
position but i think
we have some amazing talent coming in
from lots of
underrepresented types of backgrounds
and experiences in places which isn't to
say there's more we can do
there always is but given the dynamics
of having such a highly selective class
i think some of the concerns or not even
concerns but just challenges and things
that are top of mind for me
around the issue of of who gets
recruited and who gets represented in
these programs and admitted to these
programs
does also involve
how we're assessing candidates how do we
have the nuance to evaluate people in a
way that's fair and equitable across
the extremely individual and personal
set of circumstances that one person has
experienced
in their life and how do we understand
that as someone evaluating that single
candidate
we're ensuring that the way we measure
their success
is in the context of all of the
opportunities that may have been
available or not available to that
person
and so that's something that i i think
we've done a
a really i feel like this is an area
where we continue
to make progress in and will keep making
progress in and will and my team has
been really
um the fundamental driver of
creating this equity lens through which
we're looking at our process
and i think one of the important ways
that i would frame this issue too
is not just it's yes it's how we
diversify the pool of candidates but
it's also thinking about who's
over represented in your pipeline and
why is that
like who's privileged in your process in
what ways are there
unfair advantages being given to those
who are more represented than what we
might
fairly expect in a pipeline so i would
say that's just another way of thinking
about
like not just diversity in the funnel in
terms of
adding more people with underrepresented
backgrounds but also
really doing an audit of ensuring
that the gap is not just being limited
by bringing more people into one side
but also
bringing the fairness level in from the
top
privilege perspective down
um go ahead eric go ahead
i was just gonna say i think that's a
great way to to kind of reframe it the
one thing i would say is that or
add is i i don't think that there's any
shortage of talent
um i don't think there's any shortage of
talent in any particular community
i think how we look for that talent
um sometimes there can be a shortage and
i also think it's important to
constantly ask what merit
is and who defines what merit is
if we defined merit as being in the top
you know 98th percentile on standardized
test scores
that's going to end up with one kind of
pool of people if we define merit as
um you know distance traveled
you know that would end up with an
entirely different group of people
i'm not going to say one is better than
the other but i think that's a really
important question to have that
sometimes
gets lost
and quickly i'll mention on the kind of
i i totally agree and i think
there's a there's parallels um to kind
of um when you're thinking about
the work environment as well um when you
think about kind of the funnel i think
about it as like a two-part process how
do you attract talent and how you select
talent the attraction piece
for sure i think eric hit the nail on
the head of
what are the what are the things that
you are doing to broaden your networks
um to make sure that you are not
just going after the same profile of a
person
um but oftentimes sometimes with the
attraction piece it's also looking at
what are the ways what are some of the
things you're doing unintentionally
that's detracting
talent from applying you know to your
program or to your
your company um so there are things um
like looking at your job descriptions
like what what kind of language are you
using are you
using a ton of jargon are you using
things like oh we are looking for a
rockstar ninja
right that are that's a little bit more
kind of male leaning language um and
there are a good amount of resources one
that i would
highly suggest is the software called
textile t-e-x-t-i-o
that actually allows you to go through
job descriptions and
kind of highlights ways in which you can
make the language more inclusive
um so we're actually looking at what are
the things that you're doing not just to
actively attract but making sure you're
not doing anything unintentionally to
detract is important
um the selection pieces i think everyone
else um
mentioned things that i i totally agree
with on the measuring progress honestly
it's going to
depend on your goals from an employee
experience perspective
we have different metrics and goals um
that fall across
kind of four different elements of that
spectrum so attracting and selecting
talent and then developing and retaining
them
um so our metrics are are a mix of kind
of more quantitative things um that we
can easily pull like how many women are
in a pipeline
or um the percentage of women for
example that are promoted each year
um but then there are some more
qualitative things um that are like
behavior shifts that are a little bit
more difficult to
to measure um but rather than just
having kind of a pre-post training
survey
right um we're trying to look at um much
more in-depth metrics that that see
that help us to see that this training
was then actually implemented in a
program
um or the learnings from this training
were actually implemented in a program
um that we're about to launch right so
to ios point before
even metrics and measurement can be a
bit of a
a process right um to make sure you're
measuring the right things and not just
the easy or the obvious thing so
so yeah that would be my my point on
that
thank you all so much um dr thomas i
don't know if you wanted to chime in on
here as well
i'm not sure we're underwear at time
right now so i know we are we are
running close on time but
um if you would like to share your
perspective i'm sure folks would love to
hear it
um yeah so sure i think that in terms of
kind of thinking about how you measure
success it's really important to make
sure that you're clear about
what success means time to eric's point
and that you're measuring the right
things
often times we create programs and
things like that
and then all we measure at the end is
the count of a number of people
and if that program was not designed to
increase a number of people then you've
really got to think more about
assessment
i think one of the areas that higher
education and lots of corporations have
really fallen down
on is having people who are skilled at
surveying
an assessment to actually assess
programs and impact
of initiatives such that that way when
you're creating something
you're at the same time creating a
mechanism for measuring whether or not
your outcomes were good or not
not just saying this program seems like
a good idea
well what do we hope this program will
actually do and that will also help to
stave off disappointment
when you create a program and realize
that it cannot possibly
impact these three things you said were
important it's a neat program but that's
not the purpose of it
so once again really thinking about that
tie between what initiatives you're
putting in place
and what data would actually support the
idea of success
for those types of initiatives as well i
want to thank all of our panelists for
their really really thoughtful
answers to our questions today our staff
also dropped a
few helpful resources
in the chat box if you're interested and
i hope
as i said earlier that this is just one
of many conversations that you'll have
about the work of diversity equity
inclusion
this is a marathon not a sprint so i
hope that we only continue to have these
conversations moving forward
thank you again so much to our panelists
and thank you to our attendees as well
have a great rest of your day